there is no minimalist rule book
well until now the minimalists have
created 16
rules for living with less a free ebook
which you can download right now
at theminimalists.com resources
enjoy minimalists
do you see malls shifting entertainment
epicenters
since the younger generations like
myself find more value in
experiences maybe so uh gen z
is changing stuff like what they focus
on i feel like
it's it is it's experiences it's
communal
um it is very different it's hard to
generalize a whole generation but there
are some patterns that you see
yeah so i think that yes in 20 years
jen's ears are gonna change a lot of how
we experience
uh community and how we experience our
entertainment
totally agree yeah i think gen z is
shaping a lot of the culture
right now it's permeating up in a way
part of that is actually
negative i don't i don't like to see
that because we don't value wisdom right
as much but uh yeah being a smart ass
yeah we are trends and uh well i feel
like those kids are all a bunch of smart
asses well i mean it's weird you
mentioned generations
like you and i are technically if you
base it on the original
demographic uh assertion we're part of
gen x you are literally the youngest gen
xer i know
gen x gen x stops right before
millennial millennial means people who
graduated in
2000 or beyond yeah if you yeah the
original like if i google it like we're
considered gent we like were born the
year that gen y started well yeah again
so so so if you look at some
we can claim either side on based upon
what makes sense for us at the time
sure and so so i mean the technical term
is the lineal so there's this six year
period of like this this
cut the cuspers which we are and
and but i look at you you actually you
started school early so you should have
graduated
as a as a in 2000 right you so
technically you
would have been a millennial right
that's why i say you're the youngest gen
xer i know
and then and so but i i mean i graduated
in in 99 so did you we're by that
definition we are
technically gen xers and i i find myself
identifying slightly more with the gen x
generation
me too and and for whatever reason
that might be and uh eric weinstein
actually does
this whole bit about gen x versus baby
boomers and he has this whole
this big problem right now because baby
boomers are the first generation who are
really holding on to power for an
extended period of time and they're
ruining it for millennials and gen z
and they're actually really running it
for gen x because they're not
relinquishing power
gen x might be the first generation that
we have that we never get a president
who was a gen xer
oh wow we might just bypass gen x
because
you have these i mean the people in
office now are boomers or part of the
silent generation even which is
my parents generation my parents are
both part of the the silent generation
and and so they're holding for power to
power much longer and not just in
politics but
in academia so it used to be
30 years ago you'd go into academia you
go to
the university of dayton or cincinnati
or wherever and the president
of the company was in or of the of the
university was in their 40s or 50s
but now they're all in their 70s 60s 70s
and some
cases even their 80s and it's like well
wait a minute
you're not relinquishing at some point
we have to let go and
this is where minimalism comes into the
picture right is we have to be willing
to let go when we're no longer serving
the purpose dude that is it reminds me
uh i was talking about how
mariah and i finally watched hamilton
and uh because it's it's uh streaming
now
and dude george washington the fact that
he stepped away he stepped away from his
power yes because he knew it was the
right thing to do and
he had one or two choices like he either
started to fall in line to become a
crony himself
or he could be like i'm going to set an
example for
what we should do yeah and uh yeah you
don't see that happening
and it set this beautiful expectation
which by the way we didn't even have it
as an amendment that
there were only two term presidents
because everyone just followed suit
until
fdr yeah which i i would argue that was
not the best outcome um having him for
four terms
i think sean would agree with me on that
one yeah yeah all right he was four
terms right
he died i think
yeah so he died in the middle of his
fourth term yeah well that's interesting
that
but he was afraid to have more than two
terms but most people would just be like
they bowed out after
two after eight years and then he's the
first one that was like i don't have to
bow out and after that's when we changed
it yeah